on value and personal thanks yeah so I'm
really excited to be speaking here so
not about actually a specific research
project but instead as a opted for a
very high-level overview of this
question that I've been thinking about
which does have some research in it
about how do we think about assigning
economic value to pieces of like
personal data and then markets for
purchasing that data and I'm thinking of
anything from things like browsing and
location data all the way up to like
medical records and my motivation is
that these things could do a lot of
great a lot of value both financial and
societal but I want to start from a
standpoint where people have agency and
control okay so they get to decide do i
reveal my information or do i choose not
to and if I do maybe I want some
compensation in return for that okay and
I want to think about this sort of
hypothetical world and think about how
things might work in that world okay
from an economic lens but also I want to
think what's different about like data
and machine learning that makes this
problem different from like procuring on
pokemon cards okay so in part one I'm
going to give a perspective on this
question of what it might mean to own
personal data in a way that it could be
bought and sold and that raises this
question of how should or how might
people and firms assign value to this
data and decide how much money they want
I'm just thinking about some baseline
responses to these questions really it's
very early and then in part two my
answers to those questions will go into
some research projects that I'm gonna
describe it only at a very high level
about how you might design markets to
efficiently acquire data in part three
I'm going to step back and motivate why
you would might think this is a good
idea for society and how this question
might fit in our societal context and
I'm saving this motivation discussion
for the end because hopefully that
limits you know how much like ranting
and raving I can do before I get cut off
that's all part one that's all I mean I
mean I can but yeah yeah this is this is
what I have like you know a target for
yeah yeah no this is exactly the problem
right because if you say by data does
that mean that you own it and I want to
try to give you a perspective on exactly
this problem you're raising and you you
know you're probably gonna think I'm
wrong and have other perspectives I hope
I don't know if I'll have time to
discuss them all but I'm thinking of
this as starting points for conversation
okay so often we think of the word
ownership as meaning possession right
like I own my bike because it's here and
we know that information doesn't work
that way
all right it can be copied it can be
shared it can be moved all over so I
like a definition maybe you do too
of ownership in this sense as the power
of sort of exclusive control right so I
own my data if that even is meaningful
to this extent that I can control where
my personal information is who gets to
use it and for what purposes and at what
time and okay so you know in terms of
legal frameworks for physical objects
it's kind of clear like possession and
control are very closely related
for information right if we want to
think about legal frameworks for control
and I'm only thinking very abstractly
about them then we have to define what
that means
right we have to create legal frameworks
what does it mean for someone to have
control and so I'm actually going to
touch on this precedent of copyright and
I'm gonna try to think about a sort of
analogy there so with copyright if I
write a song right then I have the power
to control what other people do with
that information
right so I can control whether or not
Stephen is allowed to perform that song
I can control whether or not you know
Jaime is about to resell copies of that
song
or not okay and now I can start thinking
about buying and selling this
information in the sense of buying and
selling rights to use it right so I can
sell the copyright but I can do more
interesting things right I can sell
rights to use this information in
limited ways right so I can sell Stephen
the license to perform the song but you
know only on the harmonica and only on
Tuesdays and only in like New York
subway stations which is you know our
usual our usual arrangement and you know
I can sell to someone else or I can give
them someone else the right to resell
copies of the song but they have to pay
me a royalty per copy so that's actually
the template for how recently I've been
thinking about what does it mean to own
personal data it could mean to have
control right control over who gets to
use that information for what times for
what purposes and I might be able to
sign contracts where they pay me for the
right to use my personal data a certain
way so that's how I've been thinking
about it and you know it doesn't have to
follow the exact template of copyright
so you can think of all kinds of changes
it might not be legal for me to cede
certain kinds of control over my
personal information it might not be
possible for a company to even be
allowed to resell or reshare personal
information whatever that means and you
know it's a whole can of worms
the duration might be limited so they
can only purchase a right to use my data
for a year if Facebook wants to keep
using you know my photo or keep using my
browsing history after that year after
it expires they have to come back to me
and renegotiate or they come to my
representative right so it might be part
of a data union
that's negotiating with Facebook on my
behalf so you can imagine all these
things you can also try to think about
things like ties and genomic data like
Solon talked about but actually even
though I wanted to throw this
perspective out there and maybe it's you
know coming at you out of the blue for
the research I'm thinking about and so
far I'm thinking about this in a very
limited sense so I'm just going to be
thinking really about a single firm
approaching people one at a time and
saying you know I want to use your data
for this purpose for this
period of time and I'm willing to pay
you a one-time fee and do you agree or
do you do not agree okay and you know
that can look sort of functionally very
similar to a current world where a
company comes to you and says you know
I'll pay you to you know donate your
medical data to a survey I love the
music analogy and then very quickly I
realize the way the data is generated
though is often very different by an
interaction or in a way it's like a
joint composition yeah yeah and that's
ties yeah ties and genome data are other
examples of sort of Julian and I haven't
really thought through a lot of these
issues like there's tons of them so I'm
thinking of this you know really simple
setting and in part three I'm gonna try
to step back and think a little bit more
about okay so if you're accepting this
at least this simple setting where
someone is paid for a one-time minutes
of their data or something it raises
this question of values so how should
they assign value to this interaction
how much money do I want before I reveal
my browsing data or my medical record
it's not clear to me that there is a
meaning to using data once yeah yeah
yeah yeah I agree yeah yeah and I was
before all these they're all yeah yeah
this raises all kinds of really
interesting questions that again I
haven't fully thought through I'm
thinking a lot about examples like
medical surveys so a hospital or a
company wants to do a survey with my
medical data and draw some conclusion or
possibly possibly you could say training
a differentially private model and then
they get to use that model for whatever
and they want to pay me to use my data
for that
that could be an example that could be
an example in the Facebook example I'm
thinking more like they want to target
ads based on my browsing history I'm
gonna let them continue doing that for
one year after one year any model they
used my browsing history the train has
to be deleted and might you know they
can no longer use my data think it over
some more and ask later I like this I
mean I guess just to type tie this into
a point
mirre was making in her her talk like
it's for a lot of these these kinds of
ways people would want to delegate like
use of their data it's not clear we have
a language for articulating yeah like
which uses are okay like this sort of
behavioral nudging you know versus just
yeah like more reliable predictions
about it you know things whatever
whatever it is that the good things I
can get out of it yeah as soon as you
start coming up with policies but yeah
you're putting the monetary part but
without the monetary part the access
control community has thought a lot
about this which I'm sure you know but
what other things that the usability
community has said is that for users to
confront policies is equivalent to
asking them to do a programming task
right so there's there's a lot of kind
of follows from what I understand
not only we don't have a good language
but even the languages we have are
incomprehensible yeah yeah how does a
person yeah yeah totally agree so I want
to think about if someone is for example
you know providing their medical
information or providing even their
browsing history how they might assign
value to this and I'm just gonna give
some very baseline and I hope
unsurprising points starting points for
that kind of discussion so one could be
possible harms that are being incurred
from this revelation so the more harm
that's going to come to me by
participating the more compensation I
want to offset that this harms because
you know I think targeted ads will harm
me or because I think the data is going
to be leaked and so on the cool thing
about differential privacy of course is
that it can give me some promises to
remove these frictions right so if I'm
participating in a differentially
private mechanism there's still
interesting questions and problems so
for example you might worry that
companies can't really credibly commit
at least in the current world to the
different the centralized model in the
sense that they're not going to either
get hacked or get a new CEO and change
their mind about epsilon or so on so
there's lots of interesting questions
and problems there the other possible
way of course is to think about the
possible profits that I could make from
this information I'll finish that
thought so for example my data labor
union might be bargaining with different
people who each want to purchase
exclusive rights to use history because
they're the only one who gets to
purchase access to this information it's
very valuable okay so that I might be
holding out for more and that can raise
the amount of value that I can get
just a question is this idea that we're
holding arms preemptively into the price
and therefore we don't need other
mechanisms to deal with harms what am i
giving up my right to have legal
remedies by heart so maybe this will
help answer your question without
answering it I'm I'm gonna try to do
some games here in micro economic theory
so I'm gonna think about this economic
world where the only things that matter
in this hypothetical world are sort of
you know economic value that people have
signed to things and they're acting in
that way I'm hoping that by studying
this from a theoretical perspective
yeah it'll help you think about those
questions which I'm not qualified okay
yeah oh so a nice thing for for us to do
theory is that I think for these simple
interactions we can maybe model this
value is a sort of willingness to sell
or not so you know the company says or
the hospital says I want to use this
data for this purpose do you agree or
not and if you agree you know if I offer
you this compensation yes or no you
think that maybe the person has in their
mind some level of acceptable
compensation and that's a nice sort of
layer abstract of abstraction because i
can assume people act that way maybe and
then try to think about how markets
would work but there's also theory and
hopefully there'll be more let's say
well would people act that way and if so
how would they come up with these
thresholds so they have some value for
privacy and I'm using a private
mechanism some researchers look at value
for Epsilon
okay and then also baseline sort of
answers to a question of how would a
firm think about this decision to
purchase and like how much money should
they pay for data like how valuable is
this data to the company okay there's I
think there's this generic answer which
is that if you're doing decision making
and a piece of information helps you
make better decisions then you can sort
of measure the improvement in utility
okay for example you know browsing
history might help a company better
target ads and then they get more profit
and they can measure that in general for
a single piece of information to trace
through this long process and measure
that it seems very infeasible so you
know the firm wants some proxy at the
point of deciding whether to buy the
information or not to say what is the
value gonna be and so I'll just mention
to you how I'm thinking about this and
the projects I'm about to describe how
they're thinking about it so we're gonna
train a machine learning model on this
data that's a hypothesis and I can
measure how good this hypothesis is with
a loss function or with an error rate
and now I can ask if I were to acquire a
piece of data and it would true and I
get to train on that additional data
it'll improve my model my hypothesis and
if I can measure that improvement then I
can say how much sort of how valuable in
a sense that piece of data is to my
machine learning process
yeah this is a really this a really
interesting question which I'm not
touching on today and I'll try to expand
on your question to make sure ever it's
clear um if the company already has a
million data points the marginal value
of that million in first data point you
could argue is extremely small are you
can quantify for a particular purpose
yeah so like a very specific purpose and
a measuring value with this loss
function but now you could argue that
all of those million people are the
millionth data point in a sense right
like for each of them in a negotiation I
say well I already have one hundred
ninety nine thousand degree means you're
the million data point you mean your
value is almost nothing and that can be
a big problem and yeah you can you can
think about that as you see how I
address the problem but it's important
but that's only true if all of the data
points
yeah yeah and so that's that's part of
where I'm going next but it also
suggests that this idea of collective
action could be really important this
collective bargaining could be really
important but now I'm thinking from the
firm's perspective you know different
data points will cause different
improvements and if I am given a certain
budget to spend procuring data then I
can use these relative improvements to
think about relative value at least of
the data and say I want to acquire this
I'm gonna pay more for this is very
expensive and be basically already
purchase data in a way not that be paid
the data collection process itself we
have to pay for that right yes what
you're just describing is in place under
the labor of responsive design you know
we are trying to anticipate what's the
expected contribution of a particular
data point to decide whether we spent
the money on that yeah that'd be really
great and I'll be curious to hear how
you think it interacts with the
approaches we're doing to solve what may
end up being a very similar technical
okay so part two I'm gonna describe
maybe you yeah describe maybe one of
these research projects so this is Jake
Abernathy Elaine Chen and CJ Howe and
we're thinking of for example right
people have their medical record and
this hospital a company wants to
purchase their data to for example build
a classifier for whether someone's at
risk for a disease or not at risk
and so this is the part of the talk
where I cite the organizers good right
so there's some some research where this
data is sort of more statistics like
average height or something there's this
challenge that the data is correlated
with willingness to sell and I'm sure
the literature mentioned has to deal
with these kinds of challenges so if I
walk around offering five dollars for
medical records I don't expect the data
I get to be very representative right so
there's this correlations of you know
valuable data maybe more costly and the
solutions in this theory tend to be
things like using randomization to
sometimes offer large amounts of
compensation and sometimes low you get
biased data but you try to be bias it
and use importance for you the thing
that we are trying to do differently is
first think about somewhat more general
machine learning settings and second try
to as we were saying use the value of
the data to the machine learning
algorithm to offer different amounts and
try to focus on procuring you know
valuable data over less valuable I'll
give you an example you know this is an
example of trying to implement another
line of related work that it don't
actually understand very well is like
this sort of Shapley value of data yeah
I'm not gonna agree connection there or
is it just like it keyword magic no I
think so yeah so have some familiarity
with this idea of Shapley value of data
so I have a whole bunch of data points
they've all contributed to something
with a good error rate and I'm trying to
assess each of their contributions and
Shapley value comes from fairness
literature so it might be a fair way to
assess this is kind of more of a
economic mechanism way which sort of
says like as I'm not thinking from a
fairness perspective I'm thinking from
the like what can I purchase related
you can actually have a paper as soon as
I CML coming up basically data shock we
yeah yeah so it's a definitely an
alternative approach to these kind of
things okay so we have this assumption
that agents can't fabricate data like
create a fake medical record for this
research and you'll see why we need that
assumption so there'll be a sequence of
rounds the mechanism has some current
hypothesis there's some current you know
machine learning model and based on that
it post some menu of prices and it says
you know for different kinds of data
points I'm willing to pay different
amounts a simple example could be serve
a hundred dollars to anyone who is
between the ages of like thirty and
forty five and has asthma you know and
implicitly that poster is saying I'm
paying zero dollars for other kinds of
data so and you can imagine much more
complicated so the agent arrives they
have their secret data which they've not
revealed they haven't given the right to
use it they decide whether this is a
good deal for them based on where they
fall in this they agreed then they'll
give the data and the mechanism will pay
them the price that was agreed upon in
the minute they disagreed they go away
the mechanism doesn't get to learn or
use doesn't get access to their data and
then it can retrain an update to a new
model and hypothesis and repeat this
process doing an online version like
Erin and I'm Trina's paper from back in
the day way but I'm not sure which paper
maybe it's one of the ones I meant yeah
big different yes so it's an online take
it or leave it it's closer to Erin's
paper with grant Shana Beck because
we're not doing any differential privacy
for one time but but yeah it's just take
it or leave it framework in this you
know um a bit more of a machine learning
setting than a statistics averaging
setting but the technique is really
close
so in our technical model yes and that's
a great question because it leaks some
information the fact that they decided
not to participate the other mechanism
doesn't have that problem oh also the
fabrication problem if I can create a
medical record that is you know 37 years
old with asthma then I get 100 dollars
so it's a big problem for this for the
other mechanism it's actually also not a
problem yeah I should mention you know
we need to formalize this threshold of
willingness to pay so we're thinking of
that as a cost for revealing and it's
take it or leave it
technique is very similar and if their
cost is below then they'll agree they'll
take the payment okay once you do that
you can do some theory that I think I'm
going to skip but you know you're using
value of the data to try to decide how
to set these menus yes that's the only
takeaway that I want to mention yeah in
this case do you update prices at every
time step T or are they yeah yeah yeah
so every time I look at my current model
and I say what would be valuable data
for me today
sort of marginally valuable and I offer
to pay more for that in these randomized
ways and the the bounds you get depend
on the amount of budget you have to
spend it does because the history yeah
so um we only know how to analyze a sort
of one at a time thing rather than doing
some group thing so I think I'll just
skip the second project yeah because uh
I think I want to say some controversial
stuff in the discussion and I think
people enjoy that it looks pretty
similar we're using ideas from things
called prediction markets which I'm
avoiding the temptation to go into and
but it's using this idea of you know
improvement in loss is how I'm going to
measure the value and I'm going to pay
people for improvement in loss and you
can add differential privacy to this so
you can use a sort of continual
observation technique to protect privacy
of differential privacy of these
okay so so all that is like theory world
and now I want to think a little bit
about like whether this would be
interesting and useful in the real world
but you know I'm not trying to sell you
something I have like concerns as well
as you know hopes so yeah so the
argument for why you might take this
approach which is you know kind of
different from a lot of privacy
regulation it's kind of the same
arguments that people make for markets
and for capitalism like all the time so
it's the idea that data can produce a
lot of great social value you've seen
that I like these medical examples but
it can also cause harm and we need ways
to route the data to the places where it
does good while preventing it from doing
harms or by compensating for those harms
so that the overall effect is positive
for people and people claim that markets
seem to be good at doing this in a ways
especially when we don't have
information about what people want and
if you start from the standpoint where
people are endowed with the right to
control their data so they have this
valuable endowment it could actually be
very distributive in terms of wealth and
very egalitarian so I think that's the
argument someone would try to make
someone such as me for why this might be
a good idea okay I have this whole rant
about data being capital I'm curious if
people heard of this idea like Glenn why
lies a chapter in his book of data is
labor I know some have so I'll tell you
why I think this is this difference is
important so labor is work that we do
for a wage and then the company owns the
result capital is some resource this is
my definitions capitals some resource
that creates value okay it continues to
create value possibly unbounded value
okay so they're thinking about some
things like crowdsourcing which isn't
personal data you know it's not
necessarily privacy issues they're
thinking about data production and
they're saying okay the process of that
something we deserve to be paid for when
we interact with Facebook for producing
browsing data and maybe we deserve to be
paid for that they're also thinking
about okay we have this wealthy
capitalists
that is maybe exploiting the broad labor
class by cycling off their data and this
class should organized the labor class
should organize so therefore they say
you know we should think of data as
labor and actually you know a lot of
that agrees with everything I've been
saying about compensating people for
information so it's like 99% agreement
it's just the title is like kind of
unfortunate in the sense of being
incorrect because data is definitely
capital it's definitely this resource
that is valuable and the reason I think
that's important is that if you if you
acknowledge or agree that data is this
valuable resource and if you think
people have some sort of ethical right
to control over their data in a
financial sense as well like be
compensated for how it's used then you
should worry that I think you should
worry that these sort of one-time fees
the idea that I'll pay you once can be
exploited
so the analogy I try to use is you
wouldn't argue for music as labor where
you think bands should go into the
recording studio and be paid an hourly
wage and then the company gets to own
all rights to the song and they get to
make as much money as possible from
reselling the song you would argue that
the you know in capitalism people who
own capital are yet wealthy the band
should get to own that copyright and
make money so so you might actually
worry that you know even the way we're
thinking about privacy right now is
disenfranchising in that way and I'm
gonna try to really run through so why
you might think this is a good idea as
well as a bad idea and I'm gonna try to
list arguments without making arguments
okay and this will sound political but I
don't know what politics is so I hope
you'll forgive me okay or it also sound
echo and plus both philosophical I don't
know those things either okay so you
might argue people have a right to
privacy and control over their data and
these kinds of you know ideas are a way
to implement that okay and therefore
this is a good good thing you might
further argue they have the economic
right to capture some of this value
that's being created by their data by
companies like Facebook and Google and
capture it like financially not just in
the sense of getting free services
and this is would be a way to implement
that and then I tried to describe this
sort of economic argument that you might
think this system creates a lot of
social good overall social welfare and
so on and it's good so there are
different objections that I can
brainstorm one is to recognize that this
this method of data rights is not
actually an expansion of human rights
it's actually a limitation right because
now I'm allowed to control you know what
Stephen and Jamie are allowed to do with
certain pieces of information so I've
given the power I've been given the
power to limit their rights and the
rights of companies to do things and you
might object to that on some grounds you
can have this objection that it takes
similarly you take this sort of common
good there's a public good of
information and you've now privatized it
and made it private property in capital
just you know what approach to privacy
that only an American could think of and
you might argue either morally that you
don't like that idea or you might just
argue that's not the right economic
system for generating welfare and then
even if you agree with a lot of these
things you can worry that the
implementation of this and Legislature
might be a bad idea so you might worry
about regulatory capture and frictions
and barriers to entry you might think
that like copyright is not a precedent
that you're particularly excited about
following and how copyright laws worked
okay all those things the final thing I
want to mention very quickly is legal so
in terms of control over personal
information legal and regulatory ruts
aren't necessarily the only routes to go
so we can also try to have technical
approaches that allow us to exert more
control over where our information goes
so things like browsing you know web
browsing history I decide not to let web
sites send my personal data all over the
place like I block those you know
the good news is we have these technical
solutions to a large extent in a lot of
cases you can either use freedom
respecting software or you can choose
not to for example get Smart TVs that
spy on you and so on and so forth the
bad news is the barriers are high you
have to be tech savvy and have time and
energy and money but it's a really a
point of optimism in my opinion because
while pursuing legal or regulatory
routes you could also pursue routes they
give people more control purely by
making this kind of software more
available and I know that's a very like
you know personal opinion kind of rant
but hopefully it fits the workshop well
okay that was the talk thanks very much
for your patience so you had contracts
on your previous life but you didn't get
a chance to say any setting like data
where neither side of the market really
has any ability to anticipate the value
of what we're talking about who what
what we're exchanging and maybe you want
instead of paying me 10 cents for my
data to pay me some percentage of the
value that ends up having no I don't
think I have anything more to add that's
a great direction yeah
yeah if I can say just a quick point I
think hey I'm curious to think about
things like enforcement because it seems
like something like differential privacy
this powerful tool for protecting
privacy actually like limits our ability
to enforce these things right if if the
company has met access to my data and I
say no you can use it they train a model
privately now I can't tell whether you
actually use my dinner
[Applause]